>> Laura: COMP AND
HILLARY CLINTON RIGHT HERE 2016
IN TEXAS.
AND A RED STATE NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT, BUT THERE ARE SIGNS IN
RECENT YEARS THAT COUNTIES ARE
TURNING MORE BLUE.
DEMOCRATS NOW BELIEVE TEXAS IS
WITHIN REACH.
NOW, THEY CAN DEPRIVE TRUMP OF A
VICTORY IN 2020.
JOINING ME WITH SOME ANSWERS AND
I LOVE HOW YOU JUST APPEARED.
RAYMOND ARROYO WHO HAS BEEN ON
THE GROUND WITH ME.
GREAT REPORTING, BY THE WAY FROM
THE BORDER, RAYMOND, HOW
REALISTIC THAT DEMOCRATS CAN
FLIP THE STATES?
>> Raymond: WE'VE SEEN A GREAT
DEAL THAT THIS DATE IS NO DOUBT
CHANGING.
THE BIGGEST POPULATION SECTORS
ARE THE CITIES.
AS A SNAPSHOT WHAT IS HAPPENING,
DENTON COUNTY NORTH OF DALLAS
TED CRUZ ONE BY 32 POINTS IN
2012.
ANTOINE -- IN 2016, TRUMP WON BY
20 POINTS BUT IN 2018, HE WON
REELECTION, TED CRUZ BY SEVEN
POINTS.
THE POLITICAL LANDSCAPE IS
CLEARLY SHIFTING AND FOR MORE
INSIGHT I SPOKE WITH TEXAS
VOTERS AND MARK JONES A
POLITICAL SCIENCE PROFESSOR.
AT RICE UNIVERSITY BAKER
INSTITUTE.
I ASKED JONES WHY DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE THEY CAN FLIP TEXAS FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
1970s.
>> DEMOGRAPHICS ARE CHANGING AND
IN FACT, IT IS BECOMING BLUER
WITH LESS ANGLE AND MORE
POPULATION.
AND ALSO DONALD TRUMP WHO IS A
REAL LIABILITY FOR TEXAS AND THE
REPUBLICANS.
MORE LATINOS AND MORE
ASIAN-AMERICANS AND MORE PEOPLE
MOVING FROM THE NORTH HERE.
AND THE TRANSFORMATION ON
POLITICS CAUSING THEM TO GO A
LITTLE MORE DEMOCRATIC.
DOES TEXAS GO BLUE IN 2020?
>> I DON'T THINK TEXAS WILL GO
BLUE IN 2020 AND LESS JOE BIDEN
IS THE CANDIDATE.
>> Raymond: IT WILL BE A
PIVOTAL ELECTION IN 2020 NOT JUS
PIVOTAL ELECTION IN 2020 NOT JUT
FOR TEXANS BUT THE ENTIRE NATIO.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE SUBURBS AROUND PLACES ARE
CHANGING.
AND SOME ARE SAYING TEXAS COULD
FLIP LOU AS A RESULT.
IF JOE BIDEN AND DONALD TRUMP
WERE ON THE TICKET, WHO WOULD
YOU VOTE FOR AND WHO DO YOU
THINK WOULD WIN THIS ERA?
>> DONALD TRUMP WILL DEFINITELY
WIN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY THAT
ARE DEFINITELY CHANGING THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE GREATER HOUSTON
AREA AND TEXAS IN GENERAL.
BUT I FEEL LIKE THERE'S TOO MUCH
SUCCESS FROM DONALD TRUMP.
YOU CAN'T ARGUE WITH SUCCESS.
>> Raymond: WHY WOULD YOU DO
THAT?
>> I THINK TRUMP IS CRAZY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Raymond: EVEN WITH THE
ECONOMY OR INCOME I DON'T CARE
FOR THE NATIVE TEXAN.
>> NO.
I'M FROM KANSAS CITY.
I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS --
DEMOGRAPHICS HAVE CHANGED THAT
MUCH SINCE THE LAST ELECTION.
>> WHICH DO YOU THINK IS STABLE?
>> TRUMP.
>> BECAUSE TEXAS IS ALWAYS BEEN
REPUBLICAN.
>> Raymond: LAURA AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE LADY KANSAS CITY, IT IS
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICALLY.
1 OF 10 TEXAS RESIDENTS DID NOT
LIVE HERE IN 2012.
THIS DATE HAS SIX OF THE TEN
FASTEST GROWING COUNTIES IN THE
COUNTRY.
BUT THE STATE, THEY HAVE TO
POUND THE OUTER SUBURBS IN THE
BIG URBAN AREAS 38 ELECTORAL
VOTES HANG IN THE BALANCE.
WIMP BETO O'ROURKE CAME ALONG
THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY.
>> YOU HAVE AN ENORMOUS
POPULATION AND ALL THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HAPPENING, THEY
COME TO TEXAS.
THEY COME INTO THIS GREAT
ECONOMY AND TEXAS AND THEY WANT
TO WRECK IT BUT WHO WANTS TO DO
THAT?